what up guys goes on here and Anna Mack
what's up guys it's your boys Anna Mack
for animal protein goes in my brother
for animal pour in case you don't know
we are the two brothers behind Anna Mae
up work the channel welcome to this live
stream now we just setting stuff up but
we have big news guys
we have big news everyone hopefully big
news hopefully because crunchyroll and a
bunch of other sources are reporting
that my hero academia a k boku no hero
academia for those of you who love
saying academia is going to be airing
spring 2018 meaning this coming April my
near academia season 3 will be airing
this after we already got the
information earlier after the end of
season 2 that season 3 has been
confirmed but we did not get a release
date however now crunchyroll and a bunch
of other websites are purport reporting
as you can see here on the screen that
season 3 is reportedly scheduled for
spring 2018 April 2018 now you see that
word reportedly in there so I guess it's
not a hundred percent however it seems
pretty legit that my team is season 3
will be coming April 2018 how do you
feel my man I feel like it's such a sick
turnaround compared to when the last
season feels like it just finished so
this is pretty amazing I mean if they
end up doing this I feel like you know
that cation can learn something from
these guys yeah so we're big fans we'll
attack on Titan obviously on the channel
we got a ton of target time videos and
my near academia videos and for attack
on Titan we waited four years between
season 1 and season 2 now
season 3 has been confirmed for July
2018 so July of next year which is
pretty good but my hero academia in 2015
know in 2016 they had season 1 and then
right away 2017 season 2 and now 2018
season 3 so they're crushing it year
after year which is good because that's
how you maintain a regular fan base
right you keep new seasons every year
keep people interested we're definitely
excited about this yeah I don't know
about black clover but I definitely see
this one
being in the next generation of the big
three like this this is definitely one
of the andaman has huge potential to
become epic and lasts long time and by
the way guys if you read the manga you
know that the next two arcs which are
going to be in season three are amazing
such hype like this is not filler
this is just straight action throughout
and they're two of my favorite arcs so
I'm incredibly hyped for season three I
guarantee that season three is gonna be
way better than season one and two I
know some people are like way no way but
yes it's gonna happen season 3 will be
the best season yet guts and Anna Mac
was just mentioning to me how mature the
manga is getting right so get ready for
some more like I don't even know how to
say it but there's gonna be a lot of
crazy stuff that you don't expect I
started to see in a shounen manga but
they're pushing the boundaries yeah so
it gets more mature as the manga
progresses and so the anime is gotta be
reflecting that as well and it's gonna
be really really good what are people in
the track saying people in China are
hyped when is the release so we just
said it April 2018 has been the reported
release so only how many months is not
four months only four months from now
allegedly season three is coming which
is awesome which is also getting
definitely exciting love for the anime
obviously minor academia we're getting
some all hail illusions which is always
appreciated always all hail Lelouch
always yeah another thing that I wanted
to say guys is you know you know over
the summer we were making like four or
five videos a week sometimes however you
might have noticed that we're not doing
that anymore here on the channel because
my boy goes that over here is doing his
master's so Kasimir for life is like
goes and is alive yeah bro yes airily
barely he's been doing his master's so
he we've been busier it's been harder to
get more videos on and also I come of
private business that I've had to take
more work on because as you all know I
have to tell you about the YouTube ad
situation so obviously I have to do
extra work on the side without I can't
just rely on YouTube however we promise
because we don't do this for money
weird always doing our best
to have at least of a video every week
for you guys definitely you know that
the hope is to have at least video every
week no matter how busy we get however
if you guys do want to support the
channel so that we can produce more
frequent content so again we're never
gonna quit because this isn't just about
the money for us but if you want to
support a channel and get more frequent
content we now have some merch that you
guys can buy I know a ton of you were
asking about merch we now have
submersion you can buy and the proceeds
will be supporting the planet ready
three two one
ma'am merch showcased right here guys so
we got something like this for my
European fans keep comment Detroit smash
perfect for this video perfect for this
video yeah something like that if you
guys want to buy cool merch it's helping
the channel so think about it we have
that we have a bunch of other designs as
well your girl calls me senpai I'm
actually wearing that shirt right now I
don't know if you guys can see yeah I'm
gonna get up to show you guys well this
is one of our amazing masterpieces right
here and by the way these are all our
designs that our friend Bo J help
execute so this is you're not gonna find
this anywhere else
so again if you guys wanna do check this
out the merch link in the description
and also if you guys want to support the
channel by joining patreon that is also
going to contribute to there being more
contest they show very quickly show them
our first shirt ever design right there
and this is an animal fur design if you
want to represent animal course
specifically that's right imperialist
opinions is like good luck goes and I
think he means with masters and thanks
bro I appreciate it well guys so like I
said we love what we do we love making
videos on this channel keeping you guys
informed interacting all that stuff so
we will make sure that we do at least a
video a week hopefully of course but if
you guys want to contribute to the
channel so that we can take on more work
and do more videos you have merge that
you can buy to support us and you have
patreon both of those links are in the
description thankfully I work the kind
of job where I'm my own boss so I can
decide how much work I want to take on
so the more support we get on the
channel the more time I can dedicate to
youtube but yeah and it's it's when when
we got some cool designs for it as you
can see and to give us ideas as well
like some really cool shirt ideas and
we'll make it out yeah ideas always
welcome and yes the hype for my new
season 3 is huge so yeah recently we
learned attack on Titan season 3 will be
coming in July 2018 that was great I was
hoping that would be in April but it's
okay fine I hope we got twenty five
season episode but and now we learned at
my hero academia hopefully reportedly
April 2018 for months and hopefully at
least 25 episodes as well because this
arc is gonna be crazy these two next
arcs I'm telling you guys we're gonna
meet new villains quick revelations
about the world of mine your Arkadiy may
you never knew it's crazy
yeah it's you can be pushed back you
never know but this looks really good
and you know what my hair academia has
been consistent with coming out quick
and I'm excited and it's been popular
and by the way if you guys like the
manga we now make regular reviews every
Saturday morning we'll shoot for every
Sunday morning
to publish a new review of the latest
manga chapter they come out weekly right
now we're on chapter 160 that was the
last chapter it was crazy it was so
crazy like talk about mature yeah he's
like oh you guys you guys talk about
mature we're really getting you know
extreme she got Aki Deku crazy progress
really crazy stuff happening I know I
got a lot of people commenting on that
video saying what a chapter that was and
yeah it's good just it keeps going
weekly very much enjoying it perfect and
castor for life let's not mention
animatics past with my hair academia the
point is he's seen the light and now he
loves it so it's true I I was I was one
of those people that was like got into
my hair came I was like I don't know I
don't know I wasn't it to it but then
when I started reading the manga and the
manga got more mature I really started
enjoying it more and more it's it's
because of me and people like you gasps
for life you know I could admit what I'm
wrong I can admit when I'm wrong and in
da case I was wrong awesome awesome guys
were hyped we know you are yeah thank
you again for watching we'll keep you
informed whenever we know something new
we'll keep the content coming and yeah
thank you for joining us
chillin with us and until next time see
us save Cowboys